hello everyone and welcome to game
number two of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael tal
and Mikhail Botvinnik I do hope you
enjoyed my coverage of Game one even
though the video was a bit lengthier
than my usual videos but it was the
first game and I did have to say a few
words about the match so this is the
second game tau is already in the lead
and it's very interesting both talent
Alexander Koblenz were trying to figure
out what would what we need to do here
would he still continued to play
positionally and wait for thoughts
mistake or maybe he would try a bit more
aggressive approach for his opening with
the white pieces they knew that but when
he could either go for d4 or c4 as there
were a few instances were both Nick
actually opened the game with a four but
that was against weaker opponents that
didn't really stand a chance against
botanique so in this game Botvinnik
opened with d4 and now considered a lot
of things but one thing as you can see
the pot above the board dousing
capablanca says lighter systems or other
Orthodox systems seem to have been
forgotten in the archives of history he
says that d5 black can't really go for
any advantage with the d5 so he goes for
tonight to seize the knight to c6 Knight
to f6 and going for the Indian game we
have C 4 and now C 5 the Benoni defense
Botvinnik opens with d5 we have e 6 and
Knight to c3 e capture C captures and d6
now tal says that Spassky tried playing
g6 it in one of his games and he did may
create a very nice victory but that only
works if white immediately goes for this
maneuver Knight of green 92 Knight c4
and tries to exploit this d6 weak
weakness but there is no d6 weakness
just yet but if you do if you do go g6
then you have to be prepared for white
pushing d6 himself so tal first plays d6
we have Knight to f3 and now g6 Bishop
to g5 and the towel knew that both
winning would go for this system
he wants to pin the night he wants this
bishop to engage in the battle of the
central squares and now he will he will
try to create a weakness out of this d6
pawn Bishop to g7 Knight the d2 now h6
and h6 tall goes immediately for the
dark square Bishop because the dark
square Bishop is and immediately I mean
incredibly powerful piece and he wants
to get rid of it so brush up to h4 g5
Bishop to g3 and now Knight to h5
immediately going for the bishop
if you're a Benoni player or you play
often against the benoni
some some players go a 6 here but now
after a 4 or white is actually what is
actually better here because now after
this night to h5 move and knife to c4
now after captures captures and castles
after Queen to b3 by playing a 6 black
extremely weak and this b6 square and
this will be this will be much better
for white but even if black doesn't want
to go for this immediate a6
white doesn't have to go a 4 white can
simply play III and this doesn't allow
black to go night to h5 for his dark
square bishop so if black first place a
6 then you can keep your dark square
Bishop so that's why I tell immediately
plays Knight to h5 going for the bishop
and we have a nice to see for Bishop
captures H captures and now tall castles
tall says an interesting idea to
consider here is maybe capturing this
night this is a sometimes even possible
given up your strong bishop for example
B captors and c3 and now you push b5 and
Knight has to go back and now a 5 so you
do give up your you're very strong
dragon but you you have a very nice
expansion here on the Queen side so for
example a 4 B 4 B 4 B 4 and now already
black is threatening some ideas but tall
figure that this this isn't worthy of
his dark square bishop
so after H captures and g3 FAL castled
and now we have III
and III tell really like this III move
he he thought it was a lot better than
e4 leaves a white with a lot more
options and one thing I also you have to
know if you're an only player that white
can't go for the this d6 pawn
immediately because black and easily
punished this would be five after we
captured a point now f5 so attacking the
knight that's defending the other night
and after Bishop captures and CH now F
captures on e4 and here White's idea of
pushing d5 doesn't work now if you
capture the knight of course you get
Queen to d5 checking the king and the
winning the rock but here black has
queen if queen a5 check queen blocks and
then captures captures and you lose a
piece so botanics idea of III sorry what
the next idea of III was was a very nice
move Queen to e7 white all we had Bishop
to e2 and rook 2d 8 getting additional
protection for that d6 pawn we have
castles and tall didn't really expect
both expected botanique the castle here
as he does had the open H file so he
could be able to use this for example
for an attack maybe King to f1 was also
an idea but the bot Phoenix isn't
interested in any complications he just
castles 937 now a4 and here this a for
tall doesn't really agree with this move
Dahl says that efore was was a better
idea here for white because it tells
idea when he played Knights the d7 was
of course to go 95 exchange this night
and then tal will be left with the
bishop pair and both bishops have have
you know Bright Futures but now if if
bottom a plate efore instead of a 4 now
after Knight to e5 botanique doesn't
have to exchange a knight she can go
Knights to e3 and keep the tension on
the board but what eunuch wasn't
interested in this
after 97 he played a 4 and now top plays
95
Knight captures Queen captures and here
a5 so block
Tawes expansion on the queenside rock to
be 8 and now Botvinnik plays rook to a 2
and this rope to a 2 although it's a
really hard move to even consider it's
actually an excellent move it protects
the b2 upon as both the the bishop and
the Queen are eyeing it so now this
night can freely move for example to b5
that was definitely an excellent square
so Bishop to d7 now tau stops doesn't
stop the night but gain some control to
be 5 square but he doesn't really like
his queen on e5 and Bishop on g7 battery
as now that the rook is an aide to it's
pretty useless so nice to be 5
immediately by botanique attacking the
a7 pawn Bishop captures Bishop captures
and now B now B 6
but after Botvinnik played Bishop
captures on b5 it was in this position
and move 21 that all over the draw and
Botvinnik responded player next move and
then I will consider your draw offer and
headstall continued with a6 Botvinnik
would agree to a draw because now after
a 6 and Bishop moving back b5 is coming
a captures and now rook captures on b6
and you can capture on a 6 because black
would simply capture on b2 so to protect
the pawn simply rook to e8 and I mean so
now the drawn position
I mean it can still be played but what
when I said if a 6 was played he would
agree to a draw but after Bishop to b5
tall responded with b6 and here
botanique saw that he can keep the
position closed and play his positional
style game and he refused the draw and
style of course understood why after
watch me pushed a 6 so rook beat the c8
by tau now Queen to d3 and now rook the
c7 towel wants to at some point play
rook to e7 to kind of prevent white from
pushing efore and f4 and he will
definitely like to go rook f8 and push
f5 at some point so b3 not allowing tal
to expand with c4 Queen to c3
offering an exchange of queens Queen
captures Bishop captures and what is
controlling a lot more space here tells
rocks aren't getting active at any point
soon so best thing definitely talk can
hope for here is a draw
although even a win with white is hardly
possible but against such an Indian
player like both unique you never know
rock the sea to be sure back and here
tosses that he was playing without any
kind of a plan that he was just you know
trying to play decent moves but he
thought immediately after playing Bishop
to have six that Bishop to g7 was better
kind of threatening upon to a5 at the
prevent white from pushing efore g4 but
he went back up to f6 and here g4
immediately by Botvinnik rook to e7 now
rock the c-4 rock back to c8 now g3 well
doesn't really have any moves here he
can just wait and see what about Finnick
will do Bishop to g7 rook to d1 rock to
the fate and now rook to d3 and here tal
finds a very interesting maneuver that
will allow him to activate his rocks he
plays King to h7 King to g2 and now kink
to g6 so now he brought his king into
the game and he is preparing h5 and f5
rook to d1 not all plays h5 King pawn
captures and King captures and now that
Tom managed to break this King said kind
of open now he can use his rocks on the
edge file and he does have some chances
here
so g4 this comes with check and tom says
he wasn't very impressed by this move as
it only brings his King to a more active
square the King's not really doing
anything anything on h5 but Botvinnik
just wanted to prevent that from pushing
f5 top considered a move like b4 to
offer white more chances but okay g4
check King g6 now rock back to see to
rook to h8 and Bishop to d3 check King
to f6 and this was moved 37 again tile
didn't consider this checked to do
anything specifically for for white as
again the king is much more active on f6
maybe he can even come to come to e5
King to g3 now rook to e8 Bishop to b5
attacking the rook and now rook to e4
rook the c4
rook captures be captures on c4 and now
King to e7 Bishop to a4 now Bishop to e5
check King to f3 we have rook to h4 and
now rook to G 1 and here tau pushed f5
so this is the final move of the game
this is a move 44 and it was in this
position that Botvinnik suggested that
they should draw this game and tal
agreed because now there's simply too
much simplifications and it's it's
there's no point in continuing to play
this game now but when he can simply
ignore this and play Bishop to c2 and
the game goes on but he even he can
capture on f5 because after G captures
an f5 and rook captures and c4 Botvinnik
has this rope to g4 and now Todd would
have to exchange this rook or he loses
the g5 pawn so either by capturing or or
perhaps by going group before
whichever tall tall chose it would be an
opposite color bishop and game which
neither of them wanted to play so that's
game number two of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match tall versus both
unique it's not like it wasn't like
extremely exciting but I did enjoy a lot
of ideas that tall showed in in the
benoni so if you're a Benoni player I
guess you could find this kind of useful
and of course I did say I would cover
all games so I do hope you enjoyed it so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
with Game three of the match thank y'all
soon